Hoy vamos a hablar sobre Chile: un país
que es como si Argentina se hubiera
puesto a dieta de adelgazamiento. ¿Los
véis? Están los dos juntitos: Argentina
es el gordo y Chile es el delgado. Son
como los "Blues Brothers" de los países.
Esto que os digo no es ninguna
tontería...
al tener una forma tan estrecha, Chile tiene menos porcentaje de tierras
cultivables que un país como YEMEN que
está en mitad del desierto.
Además, como está aislado por en la
cordillera de los Andes, Chile lo tiene
muy difícil para poder comerciar con el
resto de países.
Sin embargo y pese a todo, es el lugar
más rico de toda Latinoamérica.
¿Y por qué os estamos hablando de Chile hoy? Os preguntaréis. Bueno, lo cierto es que
Chile, que sólo tiene 20 millones de
habitantes, es un país con una gran
carga simbólica. Para los liberales, es
un ejemplo de cómo el libre mercado
funciona y para los socialistas es el
Mordor del capitalismo.
¿Cuál de los dos tiene razón?
Hoy a verlo. Hay muchas teorías
conspiranoicas sobre supuestos gobiernos
puestos a depuestos por EEUU. Incluso alguno nos ha llegado decir, en
los comentarios, que NOSOTROS estamos pagados por la CIA (que tiene narices...)
Sin embargo, el golpe de estado de
Pinochet en 1973 es uno de los pocos
casos que están perfectamente
documentadas y hasta reconocidos por el
propio Washington de que tuvieron
influencia de la CIA. Por aquel entonces,
Chile estará presidido por Salvador
Allende; un político apoyado por el
Partido Comunista y con mucha simpatía
por la URSS.
"La base política de mi gobierno está formada por marxistas, por laicos y cristianos"
Como os podéis imaginar, este tipo de
discursos, en plena Guerra Fría, hicieron
saltar las alarmas de la Casa Blanca, que
por aquel entonces tenía en el Despacho
Oval a un presidente como Richard Nixon:
un político muy conocido por sus pocos
escrúpulos a la hora de atacar a sus
rivales políticos.
Así que, en menos de lo que canta un gallo, los chicos de la CIA estaba en Santiago de Chile
buscando algún general dentro del ejército chileno dispuesto a dar un
golpe de estado.
Así es cómo surgió la figura de
Augusto Pinochet.
"Es un hijo de puta pero es nuestro hijo
de puta"
En 1973, Pinochet toma el Palacio de la Moneda y elimina a todos sus
rivales políticos. Literalmente. De hecho,
Convirtió el estadio de fútbol de
Santiago de Chile en un campo de
concentración improvisado en el que
asesinó a más de 300 personas.
En los 17 años que duró su dictadura,
fueron asesinados o desaparecieron
misteriosamente más de 3.000 personas.
En lo que respecta a la economía, los
primeros años de Pinochet fueron
catastróficos. La inflación llegó a
rozar los 300 puntos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hubo un
momento donde con el salario mínimo
sólo te daba para comprar el pan de un
mes. Es en este momento donde la junta
militar de Pinochet se ve obligada a
buscar ayuda en un grupo de economistas
formados en la Universidad Católica de
Chile pero muy influidos por dos
economistas americanos que se llamaban MILTON FRIEDMAN y ARNOLD HARBERGER, por eso
se les llama los "CHICAGO BOYS". Tanto
Friedman como Harberger eran conocidos
en todo el mundo por sus posiciones a
favor del libre mercado, pero de todo eso
vamos a hablar en otro video.
"Los principios del ejército son de arriba abajo mientras que los príncipes al mercado son de abajo hacia arriba...
"el auténtico milagro es que un grupo de
militares estuviera dispuesto a aceptar
una perspectiva abajo hacia arriba".
En pocos años, los "Chicago boys"
transformaron la economía chilena de
arriba abajo. Privatizaron muchas de las
empresas públicas, acabaron con la
inflación y hasta cambiaron el sistema
de pensiones público por una
capitalizado. Uno de los pocos que
existen en el mundo.
El resultado a corto plazo es que se
perdieron miles de puestos de trabajo de
empresas poco eficientes que estaban
auspiciadas por el estado.
Además, se cortaron muchas de las ayudas públicas que había para los más
pobres aunque, vamos a ser honestos,
realmente llevaban años sin poderse
pagar porque no había dinero.
Lo cierto es que, tras unos años de
shock, la década de los 80 fue muy
buena para la economía chilena.
El salario medio prácticamente se
duplicó en sólo 10 años
y la Renta per Cápita de este país
llegó a equipararse a la de Argentina.
y precisamente es en 1988 cuando
ocurrió algo único en la historia.
"Reconozco y acepto el veredicto mayoritario expresado en el día de ayer por la ciudadanía".
Las presiones internacionales obligan a Pinochet a
convocar un referéndum para preguntan a los ciudadanos si quieren que se vaya o
que se quede... ¡Y lo pierde!
A partir de ahí es cuando empieza la
democracia y, en contra de lo que mucha
gente dice, es en este momento cuando
realmente se llegan a aplicar las ideas
de los Chicago Boys hasta sus últimas
consecuencias.
"también quiero decir que una economía libre necesita ir
acompañada por elecciones libres y
democráticas... un gobierno libre"
Durante la dictadura, muchos países habían aislado
a Chile pero ahora con una democracia
era mucho más sencillo firmar acuerdos
de libre comercio.
Gracias a esto, Chile se abrió al
mercado internacional.
De hecho, todos los gobiernos que se
sucedieron durante los años 90 a incluso
parte de los 2.000,
pese a ser de centro izquierda,
mantuvieron todas las instituciones que
habían diseñado los Chicago Boys.
En otras palabras, Chile es al libre
mercado lo que 300 es al cine
homoerótico. Su economía está entre
las diez más libres del mundo, muy por
encima de Estados Unidos. Es uno de los
lugares con más acuerdos de libre comercio.
Su IRPF, el tipo máximo, es del 40%, muy por debajo del 56 que tenemos
en España y su gobierno es pionero en
políticas de lucha contra la
corrupción y transparencia. Y para los
economistas liberales es un caso de
éxito sin precedentes.
Desde luego, si lo comparamos con sus
vecinos de América Latina, ganan por goleada.
A día de hoy, los chilenos son más ricos que los argentinos, pese a que
no tienen ni la cuarta parte de sus
recursos naturales. Por ejemplo, el
porcentaje de gente que vive bajo el
umbral de la pobreza en Chile es del 15%.
Menos de la mitad que el de su país
vecino. Y lo mismo ocurre con
prácticamente todos los indicadores que
miremos: esperanza de vida, índice de
alfabetización, renta per cápita,
etcétera...
Sin embargo, mis queridos amigos
liberales y libertarios, que sé que
muchos estáis viendo éste vídeo: contened nuestro entusiasmo. Porque salir
bien parado cuando te comparan con
Argentina, Brasil o Venezuela es
relativamente sencillo. Incluso España
está mejor y nuestras instituciones no
son un ejemplo de nada. Mucho menos de libre mercado.
Lo cierto es que, tras 25 años con unas
instituciones que harían el sueño
húmedo de Milton Friedman, la Renta per
Cápita chilena está por debajo de la
de otros países como Hungría o Grecia.
Es más, si fuera un miembro de la Unión
Europea, Chile estaría entre los tres países
más pobres.
Eso por no hablar de la desigualdad que
es una de las más altas de toda América.
En VisualPolitik hemos hablado de
muchísimos países que han salido
adelante gracias a instituciones serias
y libre mercado.
Ahí está el ejemplo de Suiza, Liechtesntein o Dubai. Sin embargo, en el caso
de Chile hay algo que falla. Y os voy a
ser honestos... ¡No sé la respuesta!
Por supuesto que seguiré buscando
información y tratando de encontrar
alguna explicación a este problema. Pero
ahora mismo, lo más honesto que puedo
hacer es preguntaros a vosotros. ¿Qué
pensáis? ¿Que es lo que crees que falla
en Chile? ¿Por qué no están a la altura de
otros países como Australia?
¿Podríamos decir que Chile es un
pequeño fracaso del liberalismo?
Podéis dejarme vuestra opinión en los
comentarios. Como siempre, si alguno
quiere profundizar más en este tema
encontrarán varios links en la
descripción del video. Si os ha gustado este vídeo, darle a LIKE.
Pronto voy a hablar de Estonia, el Sylicon Valley europeo, uno de los casos de
éxito de país más fascinantes que
conozco. Así que suscribiros porque de
verdad que va a merecer la pena. ¡Un
abrazo y hasta el próximo vídeo!